The more recent finding is this pure
fat,
uh,
where were we?
You know,
we did a study where we had people come
into the lab,
um,
to take a battery of risk taking and
decision making measures on a computer.
And we asked him to come and bring two
friends with them and then we randomly
assigned them to either do these tasks
by themselves,
um,
or to do it with their friends,
watching them.
Uh,
and we had teenagers,
college undergraduate sent adults,
you know,
30 or so years old.
And so what we found in this study was
that the mere presence of peers doubled
the number of risks that adolescents
took.
It had a 50% increase among college
students and no effect at all among
adults.
Now,
uh,
this was really interesting to me.
Nobody had shown this experimentally
before.
Let's consistent with the idea that most
adolescent risk taking occurs when
they're in groups and with their
friends.
So we've,
we just recently,
uh,
my colleague Jason [inaudible],
who is a neuroscientist and I just
recently took this experiment into the
Ri.
So we have this subjects,
uh,
with their brains being scanned.
And they're lying down in the magnet at
the computer screen is in there that can
do the tasks,
the same task.
We haven't come with two friends,
their friends are in the next room.
Their friends can see their performance
on a monitor that's in the next room and
their friends are miked into the magnet.
So,
uh,
on cue when we tell the friends,
they say,
okay Dave,
I'm watching you now.
All right.
Um,
and we compare people's performance on
these tasks when they know their friends
are watching them and when they know
their friends can't see them at all.
So they're not even in the same room
with them.
They just are aware of their presence.
I mean,
they're not encouraging them to take
risks or anything like that cause we
script what they're allowed to say.
And we've just discovered in the process
of writing this up right now to send out
to the journal that the presence of
peers activates the brain systems that
are in this reward circuit that we've
been talking about in kids.
But it doesn't in adults.
And so we think that the reason that we
saw the pure fact is that when you are
with your friends,
when you were a teenager,
it increases the salience of the
rewarding aspects of a risky decision,
which then of course there's going to
make you pursued the risky decision
rather than be risk averse.
So we're really excited about this
finding.
Um,
and uh,
we,
I was just working on a paper this
morning in which we looked at,
um,
the impact of the presence of friends on
People's preferences for immediate
versus delayed rewards.
And we were just doing this in the skin
are now,
but in,
in our behavioral research,
we see the same thing.
So we have a sample of 19 year olds and
they,
they do this task,
it's called the delay discounting task
where basically measures how much you'd
be,
how much less of a reward you'd be
willing to take to get it now rather
than waiting.
Okay.
Um,
when the 19 year olds do this with their
friends watching them,
they make decisions that are comparable
to what 14 year olds make.
Um,
but when 19 year olds do it with their
friends,
not watching them,
they behave like adults.
And so again,
it's this impact of peers on reward
processing that seems to be going on,
that may play a role in understanding
risk taking.
So,
uh,
when,
when we first saw it,
you,
you asked what gets me excited?
You know,
when we first saw these brain scans,
we couldn't believe it because it looked
too beautiful to be true.
And we peaked,
you know,
kind of early on,
we'd only run,
you know,
a couple dozen subjects and now we've
done the whole experiment.
And,
um,
it's,
it's just amazing.
It's,
it,
it has held up.
So we're really,
really jazzed about this.